[Music]
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between doritos in the uk and the us
this is food wars
in the uk doritos come in four portion
sizes starting with this one which is a
30 gram bag however these only come in
the form of multi-packs either as a
multi-pack of five
or as a multi-pack of 12. the smallest
bag of doritos you can get in the u.s is
the multipack
size which is this one ounce you can get
these in multi packs
of 10. next up we have a grab bag which
is 48 grams this is usually found as
part of like a lunchtime meal deal just
as a snack
next size up a one and three quarter
size bag
next size up this is the two and three
fourth ounce bag
next up we have our regular bag which in
the uk is 180 grams that's nothing our
standard bag size
[Music]
9.75 ounces
finally we have our biggest size which
is a share size bag coming in at 230
grams we got you beat again uk
this is our party pack 14.5 ounces which
is also
411 grams 88
larger than any size you have in the uk
let's count out all the doritos in our
respective largest bags to see what the
difference looks like the good news is
that i'm counting out this bag which is
230 grams
joe is counting out a party sized bag of
american ones which is 425 grams
so he might be here a while sorry joe
yeah thanks harry
[Music]
we're doing the math so all you stoners
don't have to
[Music]
15 times eight eleven times ten
plus one two three count out like ten
chips weigh them divide by ten
and then go okay that's how much a chip
average weighs
and then weigh the pile of crumbs and
divide it by that number see how many
chips are does that make sense
could be here all day so one chip
weighs 2.5 grams so the remainder of the
crumbs
65 grams with 65 divided by
2.5 so all together 168 chips
well we're really smart i'm i'm don't go
smart would you do that right
nine leaving our total at 119 doritos
my flatmates can eat these i won't tell
them the amount of
fun fondling that's gone on
here's everything that's in a cool
original doritos in the uk corn
maze vegetable oils sunflower and rich
seed invasive sodium five
ribonucleotides acidity regulators malic
acid sugar sodium acetate citric acid
cheese powder color anatomy
enhancements here's everything in a cool
ranch dorito in the u.s
all right corn vegetable oil which is
corn canola and or sunflower oil
maltodextrin made from corn a lot of
corn in these chips
cheese curds salt salt tomato and powder
extract
malic acid skim syrup solids buttermilk
sugar natural
and artificial
there are a few things to watch out for
in here as well as in other doritos
flavors ah good old usa only food
coloring red 40 and yellow number five
it's done everything these days and the
uk of course
opts to color its doritos with things
like a neto and paprika
a fun one to note is that doritos in the
uk and the us both contain potassium
chloride now in normal doses this is
perfectly normal and safe to eat in food
as it's used to reduce the sodium
content in salt however it's also one of
the three drugs used in a three drug
cocktail of chemicals used for lethal
injections
enough potassium chloride will increase
your blood concentration of potassium
which will create an irregular heartbeat
and lead to cardiac arrest
how many doritos would take to kill
someone i think just one if you crush it
up put in a syringe and just jam it
right into the arm
death by cool ranch that's how i want to
go i've eaten
five of these and i feel like i'm gonna
die this here is 100 grams of cool ranch
doritos and in the u.s that contains
535 calories the total fat is 28.56
grams
sodium 678.3 milligrams
it's a lot of sodium in that pile right
there we actually call those cool
original over here because no one in the
uk knows what ranchers but as far as
we're aware they are the same
in the uk 100 grams of cool original
doritos contains
498 calories 25.5 grams of fat 592
milligrams of sodium
and 58.1 grams of carbs so our version
has slightly more calories fat
and sodium than the uk version what
about the least healthy flavor well in
the uk
flame grilled steak is the highest in
calories and sodium four flame grilled
steak grab bags would be your entire
daily allowance of fat
sodium and calories with intense flavors
full-on crunch and a grilled steak kick
doritos are the great-tasting bold snack
for when you're getting together with
mates
all of you to assume i'm sharing these
with my friends
what about the least healthiest doritos
well the calorie count is pretty much
similar among all them if you're paying
attention to your sodium intake which i
guess you should be
then i would say steer clear of the
spicy sweet chili doritos
a hundred grams of these so
roughly two of these is 963.9 milligrams
of sodium
that is a 42 increase from the cool
ranch
everything tastes like insanity
i don't mind this but you gotta like
water them down or something doritos
this is way too strong
you don't need them here are all the
doritos you'll find in the uk that you
won't find in the u.s
and here are most of the doritos that
are native to the u.s
let's start with the classics in the uk
you will find guacamole flavor
flame grilled steak flavor lightly
salted and hints of lime doritos then we
have a few which aren't technically
exclusive but have some differences
which i thought were worth pointing out
for example as i previously mentioned we
call these ones cool original instead of
cool ranch
because ranch just really isn't a
popular condiment in the uk there are
also a couple of color differences worth
noting
for example the red ones in the uk are
actually chilly heatwave whereas the
bright orange ones are tangy cheese in
the uk doritos also offers a range of
salsas and other dips like nacho cheese
and sour cream
in the uk you are actively encouraged by
doritos and society as a whole to dip
your doritos into these salsas as you
can see
on the packaging here but apparently
americans find that super weird and will
only ever dip plain chips into salsa is
that right joe
doritos and dips seems like
flavor mayhem the thought of dipping
nacho cheese doritos and no nacho cheese
i think one bite would just
unplug you from the matrix that seems
like
impossible to handle but yeah go for it
there it is sweaty hands sweaty dorito
hands save my
there we go nice every episode
i need to work on my grip strength go
climbing to me it's just like that scene
in ratatouille where remy is feeding his
brother a piece of cheese and a piece of
strawberry and if you eat them one at a
time they're pretty good
but if you mix them together
it's a taste explosion delicious why
wouldn't you do this
you guys are missing out okay you're
missing out i don't think i'm missing
out i think that seems like
way more flavor that i can handle
personally enjoy
so we got the tapatio flavored dorito
collab
love to see it this guy's salsa verde
spicy nacho spicy sweet chili we saw
that a little bit earlier
this one the flamas let's look at the
fire on there these got to be hot
i don't like the look of this chip
yep yeah i would say that the flamis
flavor
reminds me a lot of takis but if that's
not
tacky enough for you and this i think is
actually really irritating
doritos also has something called the
dynamatas
what do those look like takis doritos
come on guys let another company
make some money
hockeys are better two other u.s
exclusives i could not get my hands on
by the filming of this episode is
blazing buffalo and ranch
and popping jalapeno what appears to be
i don't know i attempt to making a
healthier dorito if there's such a thing
so white cheddar and spicy white cheddar
it's simply our snacks are made with
ingredients you can feel good about
and come from the brands you love we
call it
pure deliciousness farf ingredients
organic corn or organic expeller pressed
sunflower oil
organic cheddar cheese milk cheese
culture salt enzymes
organic malted decks just put the word
organic in front of everything
organic maltodextrin made from corn sea
salt organic butter
cream salt organic skim milk organic
spices
citric acid organic garlic powder so i
think these are more organic
you know they taste like sun chips i
hate sun chips we also have an exclusive
dorito shape which is doritos stacks
this is kind of like a dorito pringle
hybrid which are mostly just like
regular doritos but then stacked in a
triangular tube
yo doritos is going after takis now
they're going after pringles doritos let
someone else make a dollar in the space
these come in four flavors and we've got
them all here we've got a mexican
chili salsa stacks these flaming chicken
wings stack some sour cream and onion
stacks and
ultimate cheese stacks yeah i mean they
kind of look like
maybe thinner than normal doritos i
wonder why these are ultimate cheese
compared to just our normal tangy cheese
let's find out
it's not bad they're pretty good they're
pretty good that is an exclusive
container shape in the us we have an
exclusive chip shape and that is these
the 3d
crunch two flavors that we got are spicy
ranch
spicy ranch i think i'm in trouble and
chili cheese nacho i like it they're
like
lighter fluffier let me ask you guys a
question
what shape does it look like think
really hard
live from new york it's what shape is it
what does this
shape look like imagine if it didn't
close off at the bottom this looks
exactly like a bugle doritos is going
after
everyone that's why i like them so much
because there's like ghouls
stay out of bugle's lane doritos you got
a lot to learn
you got a lot to learn about bugles and
you got a lot to learn about takis
actually these guys are kind of growing
on me
overall though yeah i like doritos